what we gonna do is we're gonna take it
to information right and if I said for
instance what's the probability if I you
know put everyone's names in a hat and
draw her name up what's the probability
that I pick out a boy right well pick
out someone who is is it only 15 sir or
13 yeah we're 13 or 14 right
or is any we got given 30 okay all right
so I've interested what these
probabilities might be okay so for
instance what's easy to see already on
the board is the probability of peeking
out so does 14 years old in the club is
a Oh 23 you see that favorable event 8
divided by the total possible events the
record against up to the nest sample
space very good out of 23 okay so that's
fair enough
but I can ask more interesting questions
here right now what's on the board will
not necessarily help me with for
instance what's the probability then
I'll pull out someone who is 14 and also
a girl at the same time right that
information is not there on the board
okay we have the information here in the
class but we haven't got it put down
right so we're going to use this tool
draw for me a little box make it roughly
twice as wide as it is tall and you know
box what we're going to do is we're
going to place two overlapping right and
the heading you can make is Venn
diagrams
John vid was a British if I remember
correctly a British mathematician who
was trying to illustrate relationships
between different things when there are
different qualities that they can have
difficulties they can have the same time
or they can have neither of those
policies okay so question wait pause is
it about this if if I was if I was if
you're one of my employees I would fire
you right now okay alright now to
illustrate the way the Venn diagram was
okay this big box this big box is
everyone in the class okay so let's just
label it class okay inside this space
I'm just going to put numbers that
corresponds to how many people belong in
each of these different spots for
instance 40 years old I'll make that out
left hand circle so 40 years
oh that's what our left hand circle is
about that circle is going to include
the number of people who have throughout
that age and then over here at my right
hand side I'll have the girls circle
okay
so you can see if I wanted to I could
put down all the names of people yeah
but it would get pretty crowded pretty
creepy okay so I'm gonna avoid doing
that let's now go from this way right
the middle here can you see but this way
I have my finger on is the overlap
between the two circles so there's a
number in there these people are both
girls and 40 years at the same time it's
a big sense so heads up 14 year old
girls how many do we have one two -
perfect thank you guys now so let's all
put two there in the middle okay that's
the size of that set of people once I've
got that I can start to fill out
logically the rest of this diagram think
about it
first it over here I've counted two of
the people who are 40 years old already
which means that if there are eight in
total how many left over here
they're outside the girls circle but
they are 14 so they're still inside the
40-yard circle and by the same logic how
many people do I have here I have seven
girls who are not fourteen years old
okay by the way what are great things
about this is it this Venn diagram it
illustrates for us and compliments which
was that idea we said before right for
instance here is the girls circle over
here
the compliments of the girls circle is
everything outside the circle right it's
just not girls
now there's one number Missy what know
Missy because if you had this art six
plus two plus seven at least if I
counted correctly it looks to be like
you get 15 like 15 but I know there are
23 people in the class because we
counted many times so where are those
missing eight people
yeah that's right these eight people are
neither co-hosts
nor 40 years old so they can't be in
either of these circles they have to be
outside they're still in the class right
so I can see if I add all of these up
I should get my 23 so let's just quickly
before we leave office if you have
another color this will be easier for
you let's label what each of these
numbers are so we don't put this six
we'll go from left to right six meters
you're 40 years old but not ago but I go
okay now I'm deliberately trying to say
daughter girl because I'm trying to get
that compliment language happening right
the categories I've got a slightly
different like here it's been easy to
say oh fourteen or not fourteen but it
just might be that people are like you
know different ages apart from thirteen
right so I don't want to say thirteen or
fourteen course of my percent up here in
the middle those two people are 40 years
old and okay I can continue this path
with the seven means not 40
and evil
and then of course our last eight these
are the people who are neither 14 not 14
and also
okay so we've got some language here
right by the way you can see I put in
capitals these are these words here not
and not okay
they're really important to wrap your
heads around there is one last important
word that I want to get across to you
before we leave it because long is
diagrammed
which is the word or okay so see kion
when I say 14 yours are to go right what
that means is it's got to be in this
overlap spot if I say on the other hand
14 years old or ago then you can be here
obviously but you can also be here right
because that means you're reading one
condition but not the other or in the
same way here so how many people we are
40 years old or a girl in total looks
like it's all 15 of these people Kia
right does that make sense because if I
asked any of these groups are you 14 or
ago they should say yes because there'll
be one or the other
only these guys outside then really the
guys outside okay do you don't meet
those conditions so this is a Venn
diagram now underneath this Venn diagram
I want you to draw a smaller one still a
rectangle but it's going to be very very
simple this one because your goodness I
have this overlap in here in just two
happens actually people okay but if
deleted Courtney weren't here today
right then there wouldn't be anyone in
this overlap area there will be no one
who's 40 years old and ago at the same
time so our diagram would look a little
bit different like this
there's no overlap do you see I've got
14 years old and I've got girls okay and
I would still have the same numbers in
all those other spots right if the
recording were here I'd still have six I
still have seven and I'd still have
eight but I'm missing those two because
they're away okay it's an important bit
of language which I want to help you
understand to see sets of people like
this these are called
mutually exclusive
Beatrice kusu exclude beans like you
know take it away mutually means if
you're 14 years old you can't be a girl
and here Kelly you can't be 14 at least
in this particular class okay so these
two groups of people mutually exclude
all right you can't be both at the same
time now you can see we can use this to
ask any combination of questions versus
if I ask you now what's the probability
of picking someone who is a 14 year old
girl that's going to be these people
here - out of what we - out of 23 right
I've been asked another question right I
could say of the boys of the boys what's
the probability that I pick someone who
is 40 years old now pause for a second
this one's a bit trickier when I say all
of the boys that means I'm no longer
considering because as part of the
equation does that make sense so how
many people are boys in this diagram
it's going to be 14 isn't it and the way
I know is because it's the compliments
that compliments online for teens all
the rest of them so 14 is now my new
sample space right because I'm not
worried about the rest so how many
people are fourteen among just the boys
it's going to be 6 out of 14 ok so you
can start to change the numerator on
your favorite let's we can start to
change the denominator which is the
sample space based on whatever
combination of these and language is
there in the question so read really
carefully ok